so I've come to the conclusion that I'm
a freak I was at the dentist and there
was a dental assistant there who had
spent five years studying dentistry in
Poland and he never learned the language
and he said most of the other foreign
students there who were North American
or
Norwegian or whatever none of them ever
had any interest in learning polish and
I've been to Poland for a total of six
days and I have some knowledge of course
but
how come these people have no curiosity
but maybe that's the norm maybe I'm just
a freak I think maybe that's the thing
now I'm going to jump back into my car
listen to my Farsi as I'm driving home
uh we don't all have to be the same